[Musique]
voilà mais présent dans - virale
philippe terrassiers de salazie
interviendra près de 8 et r uim appel ce
soir là lui jolie puis gens qui avaient
pour vous les bazardiers aussi à chaque
fois beblaoui non il ya un gros du
boulier a pas mal et puis aussi conne
comme quoi enroula va se tenir
c'est ça aussi qu'on tape tf1 les débuts
ont été un peu plus dangereux et son tir
en haut de la falaise et d'en descendre
on était amené des animateurs c'était
pour tous les bazardiers été bloqués de
salazie on les lui en liga 0
il est laid c'est dangereux oui là c'est
surtout la nuit la nuit en nuit on va on
va pas le cas sur la falaise on attend
de travail dessous
les gars les plus osés combes et bah oui
au risque d'ouvrir là on n'a pas le
choix on l'avait j'ai fait comme ça à
froid juge n'a le droit de les faire ça
on arrive on n'attend pas trop longtemps
pour dégager la route contre
pas trop perdre de temps pour dégager la
boue de mare à poule d'eau verts eelv où
on a défini dégager de la route vers dix
minutes après la falaise est tombé tombe
de carrément sous la machine à machiné
rester tous azimuts dont la passe est
tous abattus
on aurait passé on avait tout la falaise
du roi est défendu c'est comme un vague
de boue pour cela pas vraiment le
journal ipo avec une protéger un peu les
animaux qu'elle avait l'âme à poudre a
éclaté tout cela on était sur la route
aussi le citoyen 5 des gens pour dégager
la route pour aller plus vite
au moins les gens y laisse pas trop
engagé sur la route et salazie tu vois
la nuit' comme joueur a reçu de sony
[Musique]